let's see what's happening on the phones
at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 you can call in and
talk to me always good to have your
question ready always good to be off
speakerphone and all of that stuff let's
start with our caller from the 4a0 area
code caller from 4-8 0 go ahead hi David
this is field from Arizona how you doing
afternoon sir good good how are you I'm
good good David so I know I'm just gonna
be jurist very quick about this I know
you've had an exchange with the
individual on YouTube named sargon of
akkad about a year ago in reference to
him mischaracterizing what you said but
I wanted to see your opinion on this so
I came to discover just recently that
this individual who claims before all
about free speech and everything he
recently came out in there's dozens of
evidence showing that he literally tried
to deep platform an individual named
Andy wore ski on YouTube I don't know
did you happen to hear anything about
this at all I've heard nothing about it
I I know who Sargon of Akkad is I know
him as Carl Benjamin and then I'm now
familiar with Andy wore ski because
there was an incident where someone
claiming to be his agent offered me
$1,500 to debate him or have him
moderate a debate or something so I know
who he is but I don't know a thing about
him and I don't know about these
particular allegations well no if you
what happened was there was an
individual that runs a twitter account
named mr. anti-bully and he's a guy
that's on YouTube he's a pretty
prominent right-wing individual I'm a
progressive but he does provide factual
evidence demonstrating how Sargon uses a
ghost account called mr. what is it at
mad world one or whatever the hell it's
called but basically he uses this ghost
Twitter account since he was banned off
to social media about a year and a half
ago okay and he admits on it twice once
by a live stream on something called the
kill stream and also on another exchange
he had with another female youtuber he
admits that this is his Twitter account
and he literally was advocating for Andy
wore ski someone whose cookies
politically in law
unaligned with 2bd platform on youtube
by contacting the Wall Street Journal
and also the FBI in this tweet so let me
see if I understand Thea what you're
saying is that Karl Benjamin who goes by
Sargon of Akkad who has been banned from
Twitter uses a handle called mr.
anti-bully to argue that Gorski who uses
kill stream should be D platformed no
mr. anti-bully is the individual that
disposed a rise in relation and the
judgment Sargon of Akkad uses a ghost
account on Twitter God in relation to
his tweet and at him advocating to try
to get any worse DD platform on social
media understood and so what's your
husband for me so what do you think
about individuals such as the like I'm a
big sketch I'm a big critic of the anti
sgw community I would like to what is
your honest opinion about what's
currently going on across YouTube and
across those media of these individuals
in relation to them ad stating that
they're against political correctness on
identity politics yet they use the exact
same tactics that if they tend to be
against oh they're hypocrites but let me
add their total hypocrites but let me
ask you this would we be better off if
just no one even cared what Sargon of
Akkad does no I I don't think so okay
that's paradise I believe that I think
he has I mean I I'm a speech about
advocate I believe everyone has a right
to voice their opinion but one of the
things I have a big problem with this
with the anti sgw community is I have no
problem with right-wing individuals that
clearly label themselves as
right-wingers clearly as you gave it
that are completely honest in all your
platforms all your talking points you
don't have office key at all in relation
to what you stand right guys like Star
GaN and other individuals that are
clearly labeled aunt is GWS to me these
individuals are some of the most
dishonest individuals because they
placate and pretend to be something that
they really aren't they pretend to be
these you know like moderate or
left-wing individuals which Sargon has
claimed in the past yet he uses talking
point
I mean what's just fun
yeah that's hilarious I agree with you
all right listen I I I'm against what
what he's doing if it says you describe
and but I also don't care that much what
he does I appreciate the call and I do
have a lot of people holding and want to
make sure we get to as many people as
possible